welcome to exploring computing
today's video is web page layout
grid based layout as i suggested in the
last video
i think the technique you should be
using to layout your web pages is
the grid based layout you can go ahead
and use flexbox for individual sections
of your website but
the overall layout of your website
should be done with the grid-based
layout
so in this video we're going to show you
how to actually do that
now there's several things that you need
to know in order to get grid-based
layout to work the first one is how to
define the grid and it turns out there's
a bunch of different ways to define the
grid
and so we're going to show you some of
those techniques but if you really want
to get into it there's a lot more
techniques available than the ones i'm
going to be showing you in this video
and the second thing you need to know is
how to place elements onto the grid
if you're doing something simple that's
super straightforward and if you're
doing something fancy it does get a
little bit more complicated so we'll
take a look
at a little bit of your options there as
well
so this is what our first example is
going to look like we have a basic two
by two set of squares
and so this is what our html looks like
we just have four divs and remember the
one of the nice things about
grid based layout is we aren't really
doing anything special in our html
in order to get our layout to work the
way we want we just
have a bunch of elements in the html and
we can just place those elements in the
html anywhere we want on our website
by using this grid-based layout okay so
as i mentioned we do need to define the
grid and
we should define a parent that is
containing the grid
now if you want to use the entire web
page is the grid which is what we're
doing here then go ahead and use the
body
as the parent for the grid so i'm saying
the entire body should be displayed as a
grid
if you want something fancier like you
have grids nest inside of grids well
then you're going to have to decide what
the appropriate parent is but if you
want the entire web page again to
be set up as a single grid just go ahead
and use it on the body and that's what
i'm going to do for
these examples here okay so body
display type is grid and then i'm just
going to go ahead and define the number
of columns and the number of rows
using grid template columns and grid
template rows so i have
two columns 100 pixels each i have two
rows 100 pixels each
and then um the way i'm getting it to
actually display
that border so it's really obvious
what's going on is
i've got the setting here for the border
border one pixel saw blue with a two
pixel margin
okay and then i just placed the elements
on the
grid so there are a number of different
style properties to
do this i'm going to keep things simple
i'm going to go ahead and use grid
column start and grid row start this is
going to
allow us to place elements on the grid
just using two different properties grid
column start
grid column and grid row start and grid
row and
we'll talk about the end elements a
little bit later on
for now if you just go ahead and put a
start element it will just go ahead and
put it in that
particular grid element you don't have
to worry about the end the end's only
going to be necessary if we're doing
something fancy
okay so i'm putting uh the
element with ida in one one
element b and two one c and one two and
d
and two two and just remember because
this is grid-based layout
this is not going to be limited by what
the html looks like if we want to
put these in reverse order if we want to
put them you know
wherever we want to put them we can go
ahead and put them up there
you can also stack the items on top of
each other but
uh don't do that you'll actually be able
to see
the text jumbled on top of each other
that's probably not what you want to do
and uh if you want one of the elements
to not show up for some reason like
maybe
um you've got it set up so that it looks
great on a desktop computer but it's
being displayed on a tablet and
you know you just don't have space for
everything and you don't want to have to
do some scrolling
remember you can use the display none on
one of these elements and it will just
completely disappear
okay so as i mentioned there are
different options for laying out the
grid
and so here you're seeing that we've got
different
measurement types one of the interesting
measurement types is the percentages
and so you can see um i'm laying out the
grid
30 in the first column 50 percent in the
second column and 20
in the third column and in the rows i'm
actually using
set measurements with inches centimeters
and millimeters so
the main point of this is you've got a
bunch of different measurement types
that you can use and in fact you can
kind of do some mixing here as well
one interesting measurement type that's
provided is the fr measurement type
fr stands for fractional and
it basically provides a fraction of the
remaining amount of space
after the fixed measurements are used so
here i've got
three columns the first column 75 pixels
and the last column is 150 pixels
so that takes up 225 pixels and
depending upon how wide the web browser
window is
we could have a lot of remaining space
or we could have just a little bit of
remaining space
that fr that second column i've got
marked as 1fr that takes
all the remaining space so you know if
if i've got a really wide window then
one fr is a lot of space and i've got
a narrow window then maybe one fr is it
so much space but it's
the amount of space left after the 75
pixel fixed amount and the 150 pixel
fixed amount have been used
fr will be whatever is left over now i
can actually divide this up among
several
columns so um here what we've got is
we've got the first column 75 pixels
and then the the second column is 1fr
and the third column's 2fr and so what
this means is that
again we take the fixed amount that's
the 75 pixels we subtract that out from
the
total width of the window and
the remaining space will be divided
amongst all the fr
segments now since we said one the
second columns one fr
and the third columns 2fr what this
means is the third column will be twice
as big as the second column
so you can see here second column is
one-third of the remaining space and the
third column is two-thirds of the
remaining space and the way this works
is you just count the number of frs and
divide it out
so you know if i had uh one of the
columns with five frs and one of them
cost was two frs the third column was
one fr i would add the five to two to
the one and i would say oh
each fr is one eighth of the remaining
amount of space
so you know just divides it up by the
frs based on
whatever amount of frs you put in each
of the individual columns
okay in order to do this next example we
need to
have a row span of column span so
you can see bravo goes across two
columns and alpha goes across two rows
and charlie goes across three columns
now as i mentioned there's a variety of
different ways to do this and
some of them are described in the
handout but the one i'm just going to
talk about here
is uh we're just going to go ahead and
put a start
and an end okay so here's the body
uh you know looks exactly the same as
before
i've just got four different divs and
then here
is my style rule for the body saying
i've got a grid
and there are three columns and three
rows and they're all 100 pixels each
and then here's the settings for
a which is uh alpha has the ida
bravo has the idb and
this gets a little bit messy so
if i only want to take up a single
column i'm just going to provide a start
if i want to take up a single row i'm
just going to provide the start
i'm only going to provide the end if i
want to go across either multiple
columns or multiple rows so in this case
a or alpha goes across two rows and so i
need both a
start and an end now here's the part
that gets a little bit messy
uh the end is actually not the last
and i don't know why they did this but
the end is not
the last row or column
in the element it's actually the row or
column
beyond the last element so here
i want alpha to go across rows one and
two
and so i list the row end as row
three so again i'm covering rows one and
two
and my n row is going to be listed as
three it's one beyond
the end of the element for bravo
which has the idb i'm going across
several columns so the first column the
start column
is column two i'm also going to go
across column
3 and then my n column is going to be
listed as
4 which doesn't even exist here but
again list the column or row beyond the
end of where the element goes so i'm
going
from two to four where the two is
included and the four
is actually excluded so two to four
where i'm actually covering two three
again
i think it's pretty confusing i don't
know why they decided to do this way but
that's the way they decided to do it
okay and then here's a c and d
and you can see that charlie covers
columns one two and three so it starts
with
column one and it ends in column
four because again it's one past the end
of whatever's cover we're covering one
two and three
and so the end is four um and then with
d
uh it's only covering a single common
single row so i don't need to provide
either a column end or a row end
okay one of the issues that comes up um
previously i've
preset the height and the width and
i made sure that the text fit very
nicely what happens if
i've got a long amount of text and
either i don't know how long that text
is or
i've set the height to a specific value
and it doesn't fit so that's those are
the situations we're going to look at
let's first of all say you know i think
the most common situation is
we don't know how long the text is going
to be but however long it is we want it
to fit
all right so we've got a couple choices
here uh if
this is true of all of our elements we
can just
not specify a height so
you're generally going to specify width
but you don't have to specify height if
you don't specify height which will
happen is
each of the rows is going to be as tall
as it needs to be to fit all the text
available so you can see here
alpha was really long so alpha has a
title it's too long to fit blah blah
blah blah
and so what happened was the square just
that whole row just expands out to take
however much space is needed for the
longest or tallest item
and then the second row here with
charlie and delta
they didn't take very much space at all
so they're super short
so just you know don't provide any
settings for the rows
and you'll probably get the behavior you
want
alternatively you can explicitly mark
the rows as auto
so basically what we're saying here is
the default behavior is the auto
behavior and the auto behavior short for
automatic
is to just provide as much space as
needed okay
why would we want to use this auto when
that's the default behavior well we
might want to use auto we actually have
a mix where
some of the rows we want to have auto
and some of them we don't so in this
case
i want the first row to be auto but the
second row i want to
just sit set to 100 pixels
so this works totally fine uh
now let's go back to that previous case
where i said hey
what if there's a fixed height and it
doesn't actually fit in it
okay so here on the left you can see
that
uh alpha did not fit in its square
and it just kept on running over and you
can actually see charlie
along with the text there and then the
second case it just got cut off
and so what's going to happen here is
the default behavior is
if it doesn't fit in the row
it's just going to keep on going and if
something else goes below it
well that's just gonna go ahead and get
placed uh if you're explicitly placing
instead of using the auto we talked
about earlier
uh they'll just show up on top of each
other
on the other hand if you want to if you
explicitly want to just cut it off you
can by setting overflow to hidden
so here's the first example
where we don't have overflow set to
hidden and just keeps on running over
and you can see i have no settings on
a that's alpha uh that's the id for the
alpha square
other than just setting the column start
and the row start
and then in the second example i set
overflow hidden and you can see it just
gets
chopped off so depending on which well
i can't imagine you there are probably
very
few cases where you actually want the
text to overrun and overlap with
something else so
generally you're either going to want to
set it to auto or you're going to want
to set it to a hidden
okay last thing i wanted to go over a
more
realistic example so we've got our
complex example from
the previous video um and
of course there are several ways to do
this we could do some nesting
but we're not going to do that we're
just going to go ahead and create a grid
here
we're going to create a three column two
row grid
and uh and then here's my html
i'm gonna put everything inside of a div
with id
main uh and then that can be used for
things like
centering as we've previously seen
putting in a
putting a border around the entire page
contents uh there's a variety of
reasons why we might want to do this but
then i'm just going to put the the new
stories just as divs right there
uh inside of the diff equals main
and so again the benefit here as opposed
to any of the other techniques that we
talked about in the last video
is i can move these around
there's nothing in my html here that is
locking me into a particular layout so
you know if i want to start off by
having the record fulbright numbers
that's the main story how this one show
up on the left
if at some other point i want to say
that the
key thing to talk about is that
professor gretchen daly
is funded on biodiversity i can just
move that over to the left
i can move any of these elements to any
of these squares i want i can
determine at some later time which of
these stories should
span multiple rows or multiple columns
none of that is locked into my html my
html does not specify
any of that information it just says
here are a bunch of stories
all right and here i'm defining my grid
uh i am going to put this on the main
div that we saw a minute ago rather than
putting on the body
so you can see i'm setting up three
columns here and i'm not bothering to
set up any rows i'm just going to use
the auto setting for the rows
and then i just go ahead and put the
elements down
in some cases like the record fulbright
number uh
that's going to go across multiple rows
so i have to
start with row one i wanted to cover row
two and i have to remember that
annoying the n row is the one
pastel row that uh i'm actually using so
i'm using row one and two so the n row
is row three
um similarly for the invention for
diagnosis that's starting in com2
it's gonna cover columns two and three
and so the end column is column four
um there's not a whole lot else going on
here except for you will notice that i
am putting some margin in here to get
some spacing
there's a bunch of ways to do the
spacing
i didn't really want to teach you guys
additional
style properties so there are some
grid specific ways of doing this but
based on what you already know you can
just go ahead and play with the margins
all right so this gives you a good start
on
how to use grid-based layout to create
uh some interesting layouts
next lecture for cs105 students we're
going to
dig in deeper as i mentioned previously
we're actually going to recreate parts
of the new york times and parts of the
washington post
using a grid-based layout i'll talk to
you guys soon
you